what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cusp of wonder where we talk
about things marvel and mcu of course
i'm your host warren chris from
cosmoculture here we just got back from
the moon night world premiere slash
launch event and it was really really
cool it was really really cool oscar
isaac was there hawk was there everybody
was there it was a great experience saw
a lot of people saw a lot of friends but
moon night itself is
very different
now i've kind of given you my reaction
before but if you follow me on twitter
and instagram you know that i just kind
of moved across the country or helped my
brother move across country so i watched
it on my phone
uh one episode of my phone one episode
on my ipad
and this was the first time kind of like
truly being like fully involved in
seeing the episode so here are my like
full
thoughts or not too much of a review
because we can't do that yet that'll
happen when the embargo lives but my
initial thoughts
the supernatural side of the mcu it
starts
it really starts here
you could argue
one division kind of brought it in
because it brought in like active
hardness which is like actual like
spells and stuff like that um you could
argue it kind of comes with that with
doctor strange multiverse madness but
this was like
this is like true supernatural side and
this is a very
i don't want to say twisted because it's
not like so twisted
but it's very different side of the mcu
like even with the like
cinematography the way they film certain
things like it's it's darker uh you see
some kind of camera shots that you don't
really see in other
other mcu properties that we've seen so
far and overall
i actually really like kind of how dark
and i'll say twisted
because he's got multiple person as we
all know by now he's got multiple
personalities and it does get kind of
twisted but it's really cool how they do
it because it's not like in like a dark
way that makes you want to turn away
it's a very interesting dark way
what is actually happening here what is
what is going on we got our moon night
hats these were the the souvenirs
for uh
for the premiere badges here it was
really cool we'll put some footage
somewhere in there somewhere in this or
another video well exactly what you were
saying
exactly what you're saying that you
build off of like
what is different about moon night from
anything else we've seen from marvel and
it is kind of that mystery that draws
you in right obviously there's a
supernatural origin story
and it doesn't you want to keep watching
right you want it to last longer and
i think it's bringing us somewhere new
in marvel that's going to be pretty
crazy overall yeah i think this is
definitely the start of like a bigger
side of the mcu that is going to like be
like the midnight suns like i think this
is definitely starting something like
that that combined with multiverse
madness since it's kind of supposed to
be like a horror film i think this is
the start of a whole different side of
the mcu that i honestly can't wait to
see now each episode is pretty long
i got sent the first four episodes and
they're all pretty much like an hour
long like 15 minutes to an hour long and
i'm excited about that because i feel
like this is one where they truly do
need the time
to go into things now
one thing i really like just in general
no spoilers about the movie but is like
the whole egyptian gods thing because we
obviously we've seen konchu in the
trailers and he's the god of the moon
and it's really cool when you dive into
that and it's really cool like the story
that they give now
if you're a moon knight comic fan i
actually think you're really gonna like
this
sometimes with movies
and comics they completely kind of just
go off
the hinge with
the story like it's nothing compared to
the comics they just basically took a
character kind of took his general
powers and then put him in a movie that
happens sometimes yeah but that is not
really what this is at least what i've
seen
so far uh this is pretty
this is pretty
to in my opinion it's fairly comic
accurate and the suit
we got to see it in person yeah we saw
the suit in person at the premiere
picture picture here
we saw it in person and
it's uh
it's really really awesome no cgi too it
really looks like
right
when it comes on that cj obviously
because he doesn't
maybe maybe he has the egyptian
maybe god
but no it's really really cool uh it's
it's
probably one of the best mcu costumes
that i've really ever seen it's clean
it's very clean and even the mr night
one
it is like supe super super cool um
visually this
this
i mentioned it like before visually this
show is shot differently i think and
like obviously of your normal stuff but
there are some scenes like when he's
like running through the hallway like
they're just some shots that you've
never seen marvel do before and you're
like this is pretty cool like uh this
it's it's cool that marvel's going down
this route now what this tells me
is marvel's not afraid to take risks
yeah i mean we got that with one
division too like that first disney plus
series it came out right like we look
back at it with fond memories but at the
time who knew what we were gonna get
with that and this is moon knight taking
it another step forward right i think
they have a lot lined up
because like because they just confirmed
like what if season two is going to be
this year this year like that's what
four or five epis
disney plus shows right and then so
they're they're freaking they're working
over their model studios and i'm
thinking we're going to get four or five
a year from here on out so it makes you
think like how how much did they really
have over at marvel because if you have
four to five shows coming out each year
plus
three four movies coming out each year
as well
they've got to have at least like 50
projects in the back burner right now
that
they're confirmed to be doing and are
going to be working on pretty soon yeah
but i think the step with moon knight is
really
like approaching mental illness
approaching kind of like a craziness
uh because you know there's obviously
parts where he thinks he's kind of going
crazy and he kind of is at the same time
because it's a lot to deal with right
like dealing with the mental illness is
a lot to deal with and um
it really kind of jumps into that
and you truly do like experience him
going like what is happening to me like
am i crazy they do a fantastic job kind
of leading off the
perspective of
is this real or not right because it
doesn't leave the superhero storyline
it's not necessarily about mental
illness but there is a really cool like
am i actually experiencing this well and
and to that point it's actually cool
because
as an audience watcher you're actually
wondering
is it which is real how much of this
right like you you question like is it
actually real now in the comics that was
like a thing for a very long time they
didn't actually confirm khan she was
real until like way later on the moon
night comics so they're kind of doing
that as well
right i get no spoilers but
you're watching and you're like is he
crazy is it real like what is actually
happening and it adds like a lot it like
really brings you in there's a lot of
things like really really bring you in
and oscar isaac is
obscure
and oscar isaac and awesome
they're all fans all of them are great i
think we're going a little crazy now um
no he
and ethan hawk like everyone just really
did a phenomenal job again it's not a
review so we won't really dive into it
but uh given them a lot of praise in
this one so i think moon knight is going
to be a lot of people's new favorite
show absolutely especially for
like if you're looking for a more adult
type show right
i i think really a lot of people this is
going to be a new favorite for new
favorite before i haven't seen the whole
thing so i can't say if it's beat loki
for me yet but i definitely think it's a
contender right now so
let us know how excited you are for moon
night i think we have like a week left
and of course i'll be doing the watch
parties again chris will be doing his
watch parties on this channel as well
then we'll be talking to each other
after about them and talking with all of
you so be sure to subscribe hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on those and let me know how excited you
are for mooney in the comments down
below as always it's chris
warren
woof
you